Merhaba
arkadaşlar bugüne kadar çok TED
konuşması
izledim kelebeklerden yemek
kültürüne uzay zamandan insan
ilişkilerine kadar bazılarını çok
beğendim bazılarını yarıda kestim
YouTube'dan video izlerken bazılarını
birkaç defa izledim ama hepsinden çok
şey
öğrendim şim sizler öğrenmek için
gelmişsiniz diye korkuyorum Çünkü benim
anlatacağım şeyde yeni öğrenecek hiçbir
şey yok yeni başlangıçlardan
bahsedeceğim Ama yeni öğrenecek bir şey
söylemeyeceğim çünkü ben bir hekimim
benim hayatım polikliniklerde
servislerde
ameliyathanelerde En çok da hastanenin
soluk sarı Işıklı nöbet gecelerinde
geçti bir yanım normal hayatıma devam
etmeye çalışırken bir yanım acı çeken
hastalarla yaralılarla da ölen
insanlarla beraberdi hep çocuklarımdan
ayırdığım vakti başkalarının çocukları
iyi olsunlar diye harcadım kızım da
burada oturduğu için böyle de bir günah
çıkarma olsun
burada ben size Hekim öyküleri
anlatacağım Hekim öyküsü anlatacağım
Daha doğrusu bir tane Öykü anlatacağım
18 dakikayla sınırlı olduğum için bu
öyküleri son zamanlarda birçok tıp
fakültesini dolaşarak Tıp Fakültesi
öğrencilerine anlatıyor
Aynı bizim öğrenciliğimi gibi şimdiki
öğrencilerde aynı şeyleri merak
ediyorlar aynı şeylere heyecanlanıyor
Gelecekten aynı şekilde kaygı
duyuyorlar Hatta öyle oluyor ki bazen
böyle ışıklardan göremediğim Ben
konuşmamı yaparken şimdinin
öğrencilerine onlar teker teker oradan
kayboluyorlar Sanki benim sınıf
arkadaşlarım dolduruyor onların oturduğu
yerleri o kadar gerçek ki dı silah
sesleri yankılanıyor kulağıma Çünkü
bizim öğrenciliğim hiç eksik olmadı
silah
sesleri Mesela orada Levent'le Sevim'i
görüyorum birbirlerine sokmuşlar
sevgiyle Bir şeyler konuşuyorlar
Levent'le Sevim bizim sınıfın ayrılmaz
ikilisi lise 2'den beri galiba
sevgililer onları bugüne kadar ayrı
gören
yok ama o anda bir tek ben biliyorum
mezuniyetim 15 yılında toplantı
ikisi başka insanlarla evli olarak
gelecekler ve birbirleriyle hiç
yüzlerine bile bakmadan soğuk Ç
sıkacaklar daha sonra orada Gülseren
görüyorum kar atıyor Gülseren bizim
sınıfın en neşeli kızı okul dışından bir
sevgilisi var ama Hiçbirimiz görmedik
daha sevgiliyi onun yanına gidiyorum
Gülsen diyorum o adamla
evlenme Gülen beni hareketler y Gülsen ü
olur evlenme O adam sana hayatı zehir
edecek diyorum Gülseren beni görmüyor
öyle bir tuhaf durum ki bu
arkadaşlarınız daha kafasında planlamış
Ken Onların ne yapacağını biliyorsunuz
nelere üzülecekler nelere sevinecekler
nelerden pişman olacaklar biliyorsunuz
ama Arkadaşlarınıza sesinizi
duyamıyorsan
orada Ali ile Murat Etrafımda bir sürü
insan heyecanla bilimsel bir şeyler
anlatıyorlar bizim sınıfın en çok bilime
düşkün iki arkadaşımız anlattıkları
şeyleri çoğunlukla Biz anlamakta sıkıntı
çekiyoruz Ali orada insan gen
diziliminin bir gün çözülebileceğini
söylüyor Murat da diyor ki Ama bunun
için büyük bir elektronik beyine ihtiyaç
var daha bilgisayar sözcüğü dilimize
girmemiş Amerika'da olduğunu bildiğimiz
büyük elektronik beyinlerden söz
ediyorlar Genom projesinin
sonuçlanmasına daha 19 yıl var ama 19
yıl sonra Genom projesinin sonlandığı
Amerikalı ve Kanadalı bilim adamları
tarafından televizyondan duyulurken
Ali'nin oğlunun okul masraflarını
hesaplamla meşgul olduğu Anadolu
kasabasında kafasını bile çevirip
televizyondaki bu habere bakmayacağını
Ben
biliyorum sonra Barış'ın sesi geliyor
yür sesiyle Mental barışı Barış y
yurtseverlik özgürlükten eşitlikten
konuşuyor mutlaka ulaşmam lazım mutlaka
kendimi duyurmam lazım Barış'a diyorum
yanına gidiyorum Barış ne olur Bugün
öğleden sonra beyazı gitme diyorum güzel
kardeşim yalvarıyorum gitme Bugün
öğleden sonra beyazı diyorum beyazıtı
Bugün öğleden sonra barışı bugün eden
sonra Beyazıt Vuracaklar bunu kimse
bilmiyor barışta beni
duymuyor sonra kendi gençliğimi
Görüyorum orada bir yerde oturuyor sını
Er bu yine bir senedir asılmak olduğu
kızın civarlarında bir yerde ona nasıl
yaparım da yanarım havasına bir senedir
bunun peşinde daha ik senee Bu işin
peşinde koşacak Tabii o zamanlar Şimdiki
gibi Facebook'tan iki fotoğrafını like
et Sabah lein WhatsApp'tan günaydın Dün
gece rüyamda seni gördüm nasılsın Merak
ettim mesajı at
yok cesaretini toplayacaksın kızın
karşısına çıkacaksın filen filan diye
anlatacaksın ama bizim oğlan o cesaret
yok anlatamıyor Ona demek istiyorum ki
Üzme canını be sene sonra kabul edecek
Sen şimdiden söyle gerek yok o kadar
beklemeye Ama ona da sesimi
duyuramıyorum ama ona iki şeyi
söylüyorum benim gibi Yaşasın diye 16
Mart günü mutlaka acilin önünden geç
Diyorum ve bir gece yarısı bir bebekle
kucağında kaldığın zaman
mutlaka yorgunluğa uykusuzluğa Diren ve
bebeğin maskesini sıkmayı sakın bırakma
demek istiyorum ama ona da duyuramıyorum
emin olun bana şu anda burada Bu salonda
sizlerin 20 yıl sonraki 30 yıl sonraki
hayalleri dolaşıyor olabilir Niye
olmasın size de ulaşmaya çalışıyordur
Aman oğlum bunu yapma aman Kızım şunu
yapma diye size ulaşmaya çalışıyorlardı
Eğer İnter filmindeki gibi fiziksel bir
temas mümkün değilse ki değil gibi
görülüyor bize başka bir şekilde
ulaşmalarını yolu olmalı sanki Onun için
hep diyorum ki genç arkadaşlarıma bir
şeye karar vereceğiniz zaman elbette
büyüklerinizin anne babalarınızın
hocalarınız aklına güvendiğiniz
arkadaşların sözünü dinleyin aklınıza ve
mantığınıza danışın Ama son kararı
verirken ne olur yüreğinizle kararı
verin çünkü Eğer bize ulaşacaklar
yüreğinizden ulaşacaklardır on diye
düşünüyorum geleceğimizin bize
gelmesi biraz hayal ürünü gibi ama
geçmişimiz her an her durumda karşımıza
çıkabilir bir gün Çukurova
üniversitesi'de Öğretim üyesiyim
idarecilik de yapıyorum Çok sıkıntılı
bir gün ameliyattan çıktım galiba
yorgunum akşam 6 gibi odama geldim
imzalanacak Bir sürü evrak var bir sürü
mektuplar birikmiş orada sarı zarflar
var bilmiyorum sarı zarfı bilir misiniz
idari sorumlu zarflardan içinden
soruşturmalar bilmem neler çıkar o
zarflara bakıyorum Ümitsiz Bir şekilde
içinde bir tane beyaz zarf
gördüm Doktor erb Keskin Cerrah Paşa Tıp
Fakültesi yazılmış kırmızı kalemle
çizilmiş adreste bulunamadı Çukurova
Üniversitesi Tıp Fakültesi yazılmış
dikkatimi çekti o zarfı aldım
açtım zarf burada dursun başka bir
hikaye anlatacağım ben
size Cerrah Paşa Tıp fakültesi'de son
sene asistanıyım çocuk cerrahisinde
çocuk cerrahisinde oldum demek için bir
sürü tıp fakültesi öğrencisi var
bilirler özü fauk atesi ameliyatı yapmak
lazım yani yemek bsu olmayan çocukların
ameliyatını yapmak lazım Her türlü
ameliyatı yapmışım bir Tok o yok o eksik
olduğu için de çocuk cerrahı oldum diye
uzmanlığım alamıyorum bir gün akşamüstü
2200 gramlık bir bebek getirdiler bebek
demir anneler genellikle aileler çocuğun
adını koymazlar hastalıklı İsa
hastaneden taburcu olana kadar
iyileştiği zaman adını koymak üzere
yemek borusu Yok bebek demirin Hocam
dedi ki bunu yarın sen yaparsın müthiş
heyecanlandım yıllardır o anı beklemişim
kafamda defalarca bu ameliyatı yapmışım
Şimdi sıra bana gelmiş O Gece Kafamdan
defalarca yaptım teorik bilgilerimi
tekrar ettim ertesi gün ameliyata girdik
hiç de korktuğum gibi olmadı Son
derecede başarılı bir ameliyat oldu
ameliyattan
çıktık şimdi olsa bugün olsa ameliyattan
çıktıktan sonra küçük bebekler özellikle
düşü düşük doğum tartılı bebeklerin
solunumları hemen geri gelmez şimdi
bugün olsa onu Solunum cihazına bağlarız
volümünü frekansını ayarlarız alet pıf
pıf pıf çocuğu solut Biz de arada sırada
gider durumu iyi mi düzenleme gerekiyor
mu diye ona bakarız ama o günlerde böyle
bir imkanımız yok elimizle soğutuyoruz
bebeği Biz bebek demirle ameliyathaneden
çıktık bir person göğsünden çıkan şişeyi
taşıyor göğüs tüpünü taşıyor birisi
burnundaki hortumun ucundaki serum
şişesini taşıyor Ben kucağıma bebek
demiri aldım Alette solarak balonuyla
solarak servise yeni doğan odasına
geldik kuzine yerleştirdim yanına
oturdum pompalı bir saat 2 saat 4 saat
bana mısın demiyor bebek demir en ufak
bir solunum işareti almak istiyorum
Hiçbir şey yok bir ik dakikalığına
tuvalete veya bir iki lokma bir şey
yemeye gitme zamanlarında hemşirelere
teslim ediyorum ama ya Bir şey olursa
korkudan tekrar
geliyorum hava kararmaya Baş
düşünebiliyor musunuz Bir Yenidoğan
odasında loş ışıkların altında 2200
gramlık bir bebek elinde balonu
bıraktığınız anda yaşaması mümkün değil
o balonu bırakmamanız lazım Kendimi buna
kilitledim bu balonu benim bırakmam
lazım Çok yorgunum ve çok uykusuzum
oturduğum zaman uyuyacağım geliyor Ayağa
kalkıyorum ayakta sıkıyorum Sonra
kucağıma alıyorum sının İzin verdiği
kadar küçücük bir alanda kucağımda sık
hem uyumamak için Hema cesaret vermek
için şiirler söylüyorum bebek
demiri nazımın Hoş Geldin Bebek şiir
mesaş Geldin Bebek yaşama sırası sende
senin yolunu gözlüyor kuş palazı boğmaca
kara çiçek sıtma Yürek
enfarktı
vazgeçiyorum kendim güzel şeyler bulmaya
çalışıyorum diyorum ki bak şimdi
birazcık nefes alırsan ben de sana
yardım Edersem seni 2i ü gün sonra
taburcu ederiz evine gideceksin annenin
Birci kızı olacaksın Babanın prensesi
olacaksın sana rengarenk kıyafetler
alacaklar Kızlar nelerden hoşlanır diye
bulmaya çalışıyorum daha kendi kızım
yok kırmızı rugan ayakkabı alır Baban
sana onları Giyer onlarla dolaşırsın
diyorum Sonra büyürsün ilkokula
gideceksin ilkokulda bir sürü arkadaşın
olacak okuma yazma öğreneceksin
öğretmenlerin sana yeşil kurdele
takacak sonra daha da büyüyeceksin
günün birinde karşına Murat diye bir
delikanlı çıkacak sana deli gibi aşık
olacak Sen de onu çok
seveceksin Murat Benimle evlenir misin
diyecek sen kabul edeceksin
sana Bembeyaz bir gelinlik diktirecek
öyle meme altından büzgülü hiç gelinlik
modeli bilmediğim için o anda Kafamdan
öyle uyduruyorum meme altından büzgülü
di Muratla evleneceksin Eğer ben yaşıyor
olursam Belki beni de nikaha davet
edersin Hatta seni nikah şahid olurum
diyorum
tam le bırakıyorum elimi biraz oynuyor
biraz ben yardım ediyorum biraz
bırakıyorum biraz yardım ediyorum biraz
bırakıyorum Sabahın ilk ışıklarıyla
kendi kendine soluk almaya başlıyor
bebek demir balonu ayırıyorum boğazında
tüp 23 saat sonra tüpü de çıkarıyorum ik
gün sonra Toraks dirini ondan ik gün
sonra burundaki
hortumları ve normal annesine besleyen
bir bebek haline geliyor bebek demir
sanıyorum 10 ya da 12 gün taburcu ettik
hastanede en son 2 aylıkken 2 buç
aylıkken poliklinikte gördüm son derece
sağlıklı neşeli bir kız bebek
poliklinikten çıkarken ayrılırken göz
göze geldik bebek demirle Şimdi size
söyleyince bırak ya öyle saçma şey olur
mu diyeceksiniz Ben de şimdi düşününce
öyle saçma şey olmaz diyorum ama oldu
bebek demirle göz göze geldik bana
anlattığın hikayeleri okuduğun şiirleri
biliyorum kırmızı rugan ayakkabının
farkındayım gelinlik hikayesini
biliyorum der gibi baktı ve ayrıldık Bir
daha da bebek Demir'i
görmedim sonra uzman oldum ben de Cerrah
Paşa'dan ayrıldım çukurova'ya geç gittim
Yıllar yılı kovaladı bir gün çok canım
sıkkın ameliyattan çıkmışım galiba
yorgunum odama geldim Bir sürü zarflar
var İçinden bir tanesini
aldım üzerinde erb Keskin Cerrah Paşa
yazılmış silinmiş Çukurova
yazılmış
açtım bir düğün
davetiyesi içinde de bir Not Sevgili
doktorum en kötü günümde yanımdaymışsın
en güzel gününde de yanımda olmanı
istiyorum Nikah şahidim olur musun bebek
demir masama kapandım dakikalarca
ağladım galiba dakikalarca gerçekten
ağladım dedim bunca gece uykusuz kaldım
çocuklarımdan zaman ayırdım başkalarının
çocukları için ama hepsine değermiş işte
bebek demir evleniyor Kim bilir meme
altından büzgülü gelinliği de giyiyordu
ve benim Nikah şahidim olmasını istiyor
dedi genç arkadaşlarım Mesleğiniz ne
olursa olsun Yeni Bir Başlangıç
yaparken mutlaka yaptığınız işin 20 sene
sonraki 30 sene sonraki sonuçlarını
düşünün
yapın Çünkü günün birinde bir yerde bir
kelebek kanat çırpar 30 sene sonra
dünyanın Başka bir yerinde Fırtınalar
kopar beni dinlediğiniz için teşekkür
[Müzik]
ediyorum